en 2002 vous étiez dans le même hôtel
et Gilles vous a volé quelque chose et
ce soir il voudrait se mettre à table
Gilbert 12 d'abord m'excuser en espérant
que vous voudrez bien me pardonner mais
connaissant votre magnanimité je
l'espère j'ai dit à Cyril aujourd'hui
j'avoue tout j'ai pas osé la dernière
fois où vous êtes venu j'ai pas osé
quand je suis allé au théâtre en juillet
2002 par le plus grand des hasards on
était dans le même hôtel à Los Angeles
au Shangri-La ah bah ça va aller
chercher
à 4 fois dans ma vie à Los Angeles donc
je me rappelle voilà le directeur de
l'hôtel m'a appelé
il m'a convoqué et il m'a dit Monsieur
Buzzi et je ne sais pas pourquoi cet
homme libre existe je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'ai dit oui c'est moi
adoré j'ai dit oui c'est moi il m'a dit
j'ai un document pour vous
et ce document stomie le voilà je l'ai
avec moi ce document et j'espère que
votre carrière n'a pas mon plus grand
drame j'ai dit à Cyril c'est si jamais
votre carrière a été perturbé par ce
document ce document c'est une
proposition de rôle qu'on vous a faite
je suis désolé franchement je suis
désolé je suis conçu c'est dingue je
vais vous le donner je peux vous le
donner
[Musique]
j'ai vu j'ai lu le dos mais c'est c'est
Big Daddy
j'avais un agent à Los Angeles
que je puisse te transmettre les infos
sur le film je t'appellerai entre 12 et
13h heure locale aujourd'hui pour te
parler en direct si je ne peux pas être
là non mais il a fait le vide
le tournant du 13 juillet dans
différents décors la séquence qui te
concerne se tourne le 16 juillet de 9h à
21h à Vincennes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous promets parce que en plus j'ai
pas tout dit j'ai appelé pour avoir le
rôle
j'ai appelé Benny c'est signé béni béni
j'ai appelé heureusement ça a pas
répondu
j'espère
je l'ai fait j'ai fait je l'ai fait je
l'ai fait
ça va vous pardonnez
mon manager en France et finalement je
l'ai fait non vous voulez bien pardonner
parce que je suis confus c'est du vol de
documents et je sais pas pourquoi je
vous adore j'ai toujours gardé
aujourd'hui je me suis dit je vais vous
le rendre
merci beaucoup
voilà
t'inquiète pas il a fait le film
c'est important mais lui à Gilles Verdez
le jonclard
[Rires]